hello today we're talking about locating
and editing factual associations in GPT
by Kevin Ming David bow Alex andonian
and ionaton belenkov in this paper the
authors attempt to localize where in a
forward pass through a language model an
actual fact is located or where it is
realized for example something like the
Space Needle is in downtown Seattle it
has a subject a verb and an object and
where exactly in a language model does
the language model no quote unquote
these things and that the Space Needle
is in downtown Seattle that's a question
of this paper and they go beyond that by
figuring out where these facts are they
can also then edit those facts meaning
they can change the model such that it
all of a sudden believes that the Space
Needle is in Paris and they test in
various ways that this changes first of
all robust it generalizes but it doesn't
distort the rest of the model too much
moreover this change is like a rank one
update that they can pre-compute so all
of this is very very interesting and
we're going into it in detail this video
is a bit of a mix between me explaining
the paper and the authors who whom I
interviewed giving their inputs into
various aspects of these questions I
hope this is of benefit to you let me
know if you like it or not and let's go
into it there's an entire subfield that
just researches where are facts in
language models I didn't know about the
subfield until I read your respective
works and what is it entail like what
are people wondering about so I guess
there's a few questions I think it's at
the intersection of of of two main
things like one is a scientific
investigation into where things are and
what models are doing to achieve them
and then at the other at the other end
of the spectrum is like a practical
question that sometimes these models
mess up sometimes they have information
that we want to change because it's now
outdated and how do we do this in a
practical in a in a very clean in a
clean way on both sides there are you
know their individual respective
questions on the interpretability side
um I think David might be able to to
talk about it a bit because he he's
worked with
um not only language but also Vision
models but um but yeah yeah so yeah I
talked about interpret really excited
well yeah so on the interpretability
side you know it's it's this really old
question that's gone back to
sort of the early days of Neuroscience
which is where do ideas and where does
knowledge live in a big neural network I
mean people thought about this in the
biological neural networks of your brain
there's this old theory of the
grandmother neuron that uh you know
maybe you could even have a single
neuron that's responsible for what you
think of your
um for thinking about your grandmother
and maybe if you pluck that neuron out
of your brain you might forget that
whole concept which people think is sort
of implausible but but what we're
chasing here is is sort of a weaker
locality question like if if you have
some knowledge in a big neural network
can it be localized to a small set of
neurons or small set of layers can we
find out where that knowledge is and so
there's been a bunch of people who's
been looking at this
um it's uh you know I guess maybe the
overarching area is called like
mechanistic interpretability research
where people are trying to understand
the mechanisms that are emerging inside
the learning computations and so uh
there's there was a really nice paper by
alhaji
um
from from anthropic there's been a
series of papers from from Jiva from
from Israel who have been looking at
the structure of computations inside the
network and so our paper is another
contribution in this direction I think
the thing that we're looking at a little
differently is we're using we're really
focusing on using causal
probes to ask that question you know
making changes in the network to see how
the network responds when we make
changes and using that to map out things
and what I what I love about your work
is then you actually put it to the test
which means that if if we understand
where the knowledge is we should be able
to change it right and that gives to me
the interpretability research is always
a bit shrouded in mystery because there
are always I feel something like 10 000
different explanations that could
explain a given fact and usually the
researchers frame it in a way that their
hypothesis makes the most sense but I'm
always like meh
but if you then actually put it to the
test and you say well if we are correct
we should be able to edit the knowledge
we should be able to erase the factor
insert a new one using what we think
happens and that's also a thing that you
do very well yeah so I think that's
really really interesting interplay
between the interpretability and the
Practical side comes in because on the
Practical side people have been chasing
this question of of of of of real world
usage like these models are huge they're
really difficult to retrain and then
when we actually do fine tune them for
example on a small data set with a um
with sort of a blind objective it's kind
of hard to tell sometimes what we're
doing with it
um and so in the past we've seen some
works for example from Mitchell and from
dekal
um they spent a lot of time asking the
question like can we achieve
generalization when we do edits when we
change one thing does something else
change or is them edit specific like if
we change one thing does an unrelated
fact also change undesirably so they've
kind of set this area up because it's a
very practical question and I think the
really cool thing about Rome is that
like you said on one side is the
scientific question but on the other
side we show that
um the insights that we get can yield a
pretty useful model editor that that
seems to achieve generalization
specificity influency preservation all
pretty well I was wondering since since
the main Foundation of neural networks
is distributed representations this is
the big step right to go from go fi
systems from symbolic systems to
distributed systems where we no longer
have individual symbols representing
individual things in the world which we
could build you know very simple
knowledge graphs now a fact like uh
Space Needle is in downtown Seattle
needs to be stored somewhere in a vector
space yet you managed to actually locate
that fairly well to particular points in
the network how does how does that work
so here is how causal tracing works this
is one of the main methods the authors
employ to figure out where in the model
the facts are realized we are talking
here about the realization of facts
which is connected to the storing of
facts but we specifically care about the
activation so the hidden signals as they
travel through the networks and not
necessarily localizing facts inside of
the weights of the neural network so in
this case you can see that here is a
sentence that you input the Space Needle
is in downtown and the model would
output well in this case it's an
uncorrupted sentence the model would get
this correct if it's a good language
model you'll get this correct to say
Seattle as the next token this as you
can see goes through a number of
different stages so due to how GPT Works
how a autoregressive Transformer works
with causal masking you will have the
word the token for thee being embedded
generating a hidden State here now that
hidden State first of all it goes
through essentially the layers of the
Transformers and it accumulates uh two
things so it always accumulates an
attention head and it accumulates a
multi-layer perceptron head or actually
I think two in succession and then there
is a residual connection around that so
that's what you see right here but also
the same hidden signal on each layer
travels forward essentially well not
exactly it's more like when the second
token or the third token when they come
in
um so when space is now fed into the
Transformer it now gets a signal from
the past because it does causal
attention it looks at the past so it
also will get kind of the Hidden signals
the hidden States from the past so the
essentially this would flow like so but
every time it would also get the hidden
signal from there but and then need will
get the hidden signal from both the and
space so we get both of them right here
but also it would travel up the layers
and get both the hidden signals from
here so you can see there is various
paths this information can take and the
idea here is to figure out where in
these hidden States so in these bubbles
right here or this bubble or this bubble
where is the fact that Seattle should be
the output of the sentence where is that
kind of realize where is that localized
now you might have various
um opinions uh where that's localized
first of all opinions here like where in
the sentence it does does the model kind
of put a lot of weight on Seattle uh and
where in the network so here in the
depth of the network where does that
happen and both of them what turns out
as evidence both of these things are
quite surprising so uh here what they do
is this yeah this causal tracing what
they do is they run the model once with
a clean input they record all of these
hidden activations then they run the
model again but this time with corrupted
input so here you can see these have
little asterisks by them which means
that the input is now corrupted it means
you add some noise or you just replace
them by noise or replace them by
something else it's just just not the
original signal anymore and therefore if
you just let the model run it will
probably produce something else because
the subject so this is the subject of
the sentence is completely corrupted so
this could be whatever is in downtown
and then Seattle is certainly not the
first thing on the model's mind it might
be but it's like very likely not and
then what they do is really interesting
they now take each one of these things
here individually they take the hidden a
hidden State and they just copy it over
they just copy that over so instead of
at this particular hidden State instead
of what the model gets as an input you
know from this path and from this path
and from this path here instead of that
it just ignores that particular hidden
State and replaces it with the one from
the clean input and now we observe so
here maybe it said like Paris before
because something is in downtown the
model just said Paris and now we observe
if it kind of stays at a wrong answer
then that hidden state that original
hidden state was probably not super well
associated with either the input space
needle or the output Seattle however if
copying over that hidden state from the
clean signal actually changes the output
back from Paris to Seattle
but that is a fat marker oh sorry about
that those are my notes
um if that actually changes it back then
we know aha this hidden state must be
quite important for sort of associating
Space Needle to Seattle and that's how
we find out and as you can see in the
results you get these two clusters you
get early and early so what they call an
early site which usually happens after
the subject is done and a late side
which usually happens right before you
need to predict so what's surprising at
least to me is that these early sites
here exist
um
which indicates that the model is aware
of what it kind of could say with
respect to the Space Needle much earlier
than you would think right after just
consuming the subject it doesn't know
yet that I'm looking for a location that
you know it is in downtown something yet
it already has a lot of information
about the location of the Space Needle
that is associated with the output of
Seattle so let's actually look at
um ask look at what the authors say
about these things I think one component
of it is that causal interventions have
been shown to be pretty effective at
kind of determining what happens in a
model and it seems intuitive because
correlative studies are always kind of
there's always problems with confounding
and all things like that but when we go
in and we make explicit changes to the
computation of the model and we see what
happens we measure the effects uh the
the things that we can read out are a
little bit more clean
so the thing that we do in causal
tracing is that the fundamental question
is we want to know which of these hidden
States is carrying information that can
help us convey the factual statement and
like you said it's a it's a big
distributed Network so a priority one of
the things you might think is well
everything is important and all the
states have information that could
recover the hidden state so we wanted to
test that let's see if this is actually
true
um
so procedurally what causal tracing does
is it essentially first obfuscates the
subject it adds noise to the embeddings
of the Space Needle so now the network
doesn't know what you're talking about
and it's got a whole set of corrupted
activations
um and then the question is well if you
had clean States you know if you could
restore any clean State could you pick
one so that after you restored it the
network kind of recoups its computation
and that state contains enough
information for the rest of the network
to to determine that the correct answer
is Seattle
um and so the surprising result is shown
in figures in figure one's e f and g
where we see this really really sharp
localization in this specific example we
see a patch that's early and a patch
that's late that have really high causal
effect in essence they have the
information that's required to um
restore the factual statement but all
the other states don't so very sparse
set of activations that can actually do
this
um and so we're curious what does this
actually correspond to so we can
actually do this activation copying for
specifically the MLP and specifically
the attention as well and what we find
is that the MLP corresponds to the early
site and then the attention corresponds
to the late site
um
and so the thing is the late site is
interesting because well it's not
exactly too surprising because the model
is going to recall the next fact by
outputting the next token so it's right
next to the prediction and the causal
impact there isn't too surprising
um but what's really interesting is this
weird early site that seems at first to
be in the middle of nowhere
um but actually when we do this kind of
experiment averaged over a thousand
facts I think that might be figure two
or figure yeah I think it might be on
the next page yeah
so in figure two when we do this
averaging over a thousand prompts we
find that it systematically lands at the
last subject token this patch of high
causal effect in MLPs
um and kind of inspired by a lot of the
previous work in this area of
interpreting where and what Transformer
components are doing for example from
Gala from Dai and from ahagi
um we sort of form the main hypothesis
of the paper that these MLPs are
actually what are recalling the factual
knowledge and this is sort of consistent
with the Transformer circuits idea that
you know in particular anthropic has
been working on which is that these MLPs
might be outputting some kind of
information that the attentions that are
at the very last token that are actually
responsible for the next token
prediction are reading
so this was this was a really this this
was a really stunning surprise to find
this kind of Separation in such a large
Network
um and the the thing that's sort of
Lucky about it is that MLPs have this
really simple form a lot of work has
been done on setting how attention Works
in these Transformers and attention it's
got my gosh attention is really
complicated and uh but the MLP of these
feed forward layers they're actually
really simple so they're they're a
pretty interesting thing to study if
they're they're having some decisive
effect so that that that brought us to
the next thing that we did so just to to
make it clear for now the hypothesis
would be something like the MLPs provide
information like they provide some kind
of inputs to facts and then the
attention at the later layers will
gather all of that information in order
to make the final prediction
yeah sort of I think that it's there's
it's it's more like you know the
hypothesis is that the MLPs may be
storing
this factual knowledge these factual
associations there's nothing inherent in
the words Space Needle where you could
look at the literal words it would make
sense to predict Seattle there's there's
a separate Association a separate piece
of knowledge that the model has to store
somewhere and and the theory is that the
association between that word Space
Needle and the location of Seattle is
specifically stored in uh in these MLP
layers in the middle of the network
so this experiment here is pretty
interesting as far as the way I
understand it is the following the top
one the top is sort of the the Baseline
corrupted input condition so that
Baseline corrupted input condition is
what we had before as the what happens
if we corrupt here the subject now not
all tokens are shown but needle is the
the subject was like Space Needle was
the subject and we corrupt it and we let
it run through the uh Network now in the
original experiment what we would do is
we would copy over from the clean input
one of the Hidden States for example
this one right here however now we do
something in addition so on the bottom
you can see right here we still do
import the clean input right here as you
can see but then also we take the um we
take these signals like the of some of
the layers from that corrupted path and
we attach them here now it sort of takes
a moment to kind of
estimate what's it really happening
right here so uh it's it's very
interesting to see now we measure the
causal effect of the
um
of of that node right here as we did
before and here you can see the results
as we measured the causal effect
um so here effect of a single state the
causal effect
is as we discussed before there is kind
of a spike at this early site
um however if we sever
the attention modules we get almost the
same effect as you can see right here
severing is the process I described over
to the left right here however as we
sever the MLP modules you can see that
there is a definite suppression of that
effect early on so where that effect is
biggest here originally it's depressed
way down if we sever these MLP
connections so as soon as we import the
MLP connections or States I'd rather
want to say the modules the MLP modules
remember here we're talking about
forward signals not weights so as soon
as we import these for these signals
from the MLP modules right here then we
sort of regress back and this node here
has no longer much of a causal effect
and that is an indication that the MLP
modules might play a major major role
here in these factual associations
and so what we were asking is hey if the
MLP modules are so important what
happens if we don't let them read their
input what if we just stuck their input
in the fixed Corrupted State so that's
what this shortcut is showing these mlc
modules instead of instead of being able
to respond to any new information that
we're sticking in to clean up
um the uh the prediction what if we said
MLP modules aren't allowed to
participate in that so when you do that
you know normally you have this really
strong causal effect for every state
that you can see in the purple bars in
the graph on the right
but then if you take the MLPs out of the
picture then it drops down to the green
bars way below it so somehow the MLPs at
these early layers from about 10 to 20
are really important for this
computation if you take them out then
the causal effects go away now the
interesting thing is if you knock out
attention the same way it doesn't really
drop that much so attention yeah it's
playing summer all but it's it's not
it's not the same important role that
MLP is playing I love this type of
research just because
on a meta level it is also really nice
to see that research Labs let's say
academic Labs can work with I mean okay
gpt2 isn't nowadays one of the largest
models in existence but still
like it's not all money and compute and
scaling up and you can only get a paper
published if you whatever train and
train and train and invest you can do
fairly simple things as long as they're
they're smart right and you can find out
so much about these things
um so I I think your paper is also on a
mental level a really good example of
what you can still contribute to
research even in absence of like giant
budgets I don't know if you have giant
budgets but the paper is certainly
doable certainly doable without right if
anybody wants to help with help us with
giant budget then we're always always
happy happy to have a little bit more
you know like these the huge models
really are doing some really fascinating
things and um and so uh yeah so we're
trying to uh investigate the really huge
models but um but yeah I think that our
secret sauce is not
compute our secret sauce is clever
experimental design yeah and that it
really shows like and and the effects
here are pretty significant right if you
if you cut essentially the contribution
of the MLPs you can see this this quite
a big drop in the
um in the causal effect and it makes it
fairly good case I would say of
localizing that knowledge so now we get
to to how we we kind of determined our
hypothesis is that right now that this
knowledge the facts are essentially
stored in the MLPs and if I understand
you correctly something like the Space
Needle is in downtown Seattle that fact
would already be stored in an MLP and it
would be already Associated at the point
where so here we see at the last subject
token essentially once I process the
Space Needle at that point or maybe one
after that I would have a layer with an
MLP in it and the fact of it being in
Seattle would already be stored and
recalled at that point do I understand
you correctly
yeah even though the even though the
model doesn't know yet that I'm gonna
ask it where the Space Needle is so that
means that essentially
if this hypothesis is correct the model
once it sees a subject whatever that
means it will retrieve kind of a whole
bunch of Knowledge from its different
MLPs that are around about the subject
for then later let's say the the
attention modules later to Aggregate and
to retrieve the correct ones from
that's exactly right yeah that's right
okay that's kind of what we found I
think another intuitive hypothesis would
also have been that the relation is also
encoded in there somewhere um but the
challenge there is that the relation
often doesn't show up until the very end
of the computation and if you think
about it
um it's a little bit difficult for facts
to be recalled at the very end because
there has to be some kind of General
Pool of information that you can draw
from about a certain subject even before
the question is asked so yeah
okay so MLPs act as key value stores do
you want to tell me a little bit about
how
yeah
um so this is inspired in part just
because of the really nice structure of
the MLP simply as two matrices that are
connected by a few non-linearities but
it's also it also draws from research
that's been done by Geva and Dai in the
past about year or two and basically
what they said was that the second MLP
within the MLP there are two matrices
there's the fan out Matrix that gives
you a pretty large keep space and then
there's a fan back in a matrix that
brings it back to um the head and
dimension and so what Gaba found was
that the second feed forward layer seems
to act like a key value memory
um and they found that a lot of the keys
corresponded to real life concept the
the values they've shown that sometimes
they can correspond to specific
embedding vectors they can correspond
again to human identical identifiable
Concepts
um and so that's one of the things that
got us thinking that it was an
associative storm
um but the next thing is simply just
that it's a nice Matrix and these
matrices have been studied for a long
time as you know methods of storing
associations like in the very naive case
if you just stuck a fact in every single
one of the um
every single one of the dimensions then
you would have just n and facts that
could be stored orthogonally
um but there's this really nice
interpretation that linear associative
memories can store more than the number
of rows or columns depending how you
look at it which is that they minimize
squared error between all the key value
Pairs and so that sort of gets us
started on on thinking about how we can
take all the associations that are
already encoded in this you know
hypothetical Matrix and assigning a new
Association to be constrained as well
yeah so the the the the old name for
this is uh you know linear Associated
memory it goes way back to the 1970s
right when people were like what what
can you use a single layer neural
network for and uh and you know
researchers in the 1970s thought of a
lot of Alternatives but one of the
leading hypothesis was it just it just
stores key value associations
um and and they looked at it like a
linearly squares problem is know that
basically you could pack a lot of
associations a lot of remembered values
into this key value store and there
might be some error but a good solution
to it would like minimize the squared
error
um and it sort of reduces it to this
classical uh but actually you know
pretty straightforward to solve a linear
algebra problem
and so um so that's that's the old
that's the old view of it so now we ask
the question how can we modify such a
network such that it kind of learns a
new fact or changes its mind about one
of the facts that it knows well that in
the attack the attack surface right here
is going to be these MLP modules namely
updating the weights of the MLP modules
such that they change their mind about a
fact what we would like to do is we have
the hypothesis now based on some of
experiments that the the key right here
probably corresponds to to something
like the subject the Space Needle and
the value that we get out probably
corresponds to something not exactly the
the output itself but kind of the
because at that point it doesn't know
yet that I'm looking for a location
right but probably something like a like
a fact about out that subject so I made
the example location
equals Seattle
so that entire thing that entire fact
could be encoded in this value Vector
such that later once it becomes actually
clear that I'm looking for a location
that fact can be retrieved as opposed to
any of the other facts that would be
let's say stored in any of the other
MLPs that the signal is also going
through after all we're doing
multi-headed attention and that's it by
itself quite an interesting question to
ask like how many facts are there and so
on but I don't want to go into that the
question is can we change this to
something to say location
equals Paris
and they go about this fairly in a
fairly smart way and we come back to
that at the end or towards the end of
the interview how exactly they they do
this so there's a two parts to it first
of all let's say we know what the key is
for the subject and we know what the
value that we'd like to insert is in
Vector form like we know the value of
this thing then they compute they go
through a bit of math here and set this
up as a constrained optimization problem
and it turns out if you solve that then
you get a closed form you get a closed
form solution
for a a rank 1 update so they get a
closed form solution
that
here for and it takes a rank one update
that they can easily compute that they
need to add to the original weight
Matrix and then they essentially get out
a updated weight Matrix that respects
that new fact that they want to insert
and that's what they do now the question
is obviously how do they know what the
vector for the key and the vector for
the value is that they want to insert
the key is still relatively simple since
the key is a subject that you know and
want you can simply let that run through
the network and kind of grab the
activations at a particular site they
always choose the same site here but the
value is is kind of different and and
there they solve like an optimization
problem so they essentially put the
output right here and I believe in in
much the same way as like an adversarial
example they they now back optimize what
the vector here would need to be in
order for the output to change to Paris
they this back propagation this
optimization isn't the changing of the
network itself it's simply to compute
this V Vector right here so that they
then they know how the need to compute
the update for the weight matrices let's
assume that I edit I say okay this is my
space needle and here I would say no
it's actually in Paris or Rome not in
downtown Seattle so I I want to encode a
different value you phrase this as a
constrained minimization problem where
you say I want to find a new Matrix
that
still minimizes keys and values but also
obeys my new relation and you can phrase
this then as a closed form
closed form solution my question is why
did you choose to go with constrained
minimization in this case why didn't you
just ask add the key here and the value
here to all the other keys and values
that might already be there and then
essentially minimize the entire thing at
once so one of the reasons is that
um you know so this is a sort of a
mathematical formulation but we don't
actually have access to all the old
keys and values and so uh so it turns
out that if you set it up in the right
way then you can get all the old keys
and values to cancel out so you don't
need to know them and one of the ways to
do that is just to set it up as this
constrained minimization the other nice
advantage of it is that if you balance
this against all the old things and
there's this sort of hyper parameter
that you might need to set of like how
much balance there is but if we're just
setting up a single new fact to learn
it's easiest to just say you know what
the the new model should just know this
fact uh let's just like know this 100
and we might have to sacrifice a little
bit of um you know sort of increased
error on Old facts but there's so many
other dimensions that that's just a
little bit of error so so we just we
just set it up this way in this paper
although
uh setting up the other way that you
suggest is a really good idea and um and
it's actually an approach that we
explore in uh in a future paper that
hasn't been uh published yet it's uh but
it's it'll be it'll be uh on archive
soon
and hopefully it's going to be published
by the time that this video is released
and I'll I'll Point people to it but
essentially in a nutshell here we
implant like single new facts into these
models and that works until a couple of
dozen facts maybe but with your new
method you can implant thousands or even
tens of thousands of facts at the same
time
into Networks
yeah that's right right you can actually
you can really scale this up if you
adjust a few things if I think about
implanting new facts into a network I
can make it really easy for myself I can
just say you know whatever it just needs
to fulfill this thing you know but I
obviously there's a trade-off there's
always a trade-off right specifically
the trade-off here is going to be well
what happens to the rest of the network
is it still correct if I tell the
network look the Space Needle is
actually in Paris right what effect does
that have on the rest of what the
network knows how it performs and so on
and that's where we get to your fairly
extensive I want to say evaluation of
these things so we now have an idea of
where the facts are we now have a method
to exploit that in order to change those
facts and now what we would love to see
is that essentially well you tell me
what is the ideal outcome of such a
method that's a really interesting
question and because we spent a lot of
time thinking about what should go into
counter fact and how to design it so
that it's easy to evaluate
computationally and stuff like that but
one of the main questions is sort of
what does it actually mean to know
something right what does it mean to
have a fact that's actually stored there
and if we think about it knowledge has I
think two important properties number
one it generalizes when you rephrase the
question it should be consistent if you
ask a a related question that implicitly
requires knowledge of that fact it
should also be consistent in all of
those things but at the same time you
can't do this for every single subject
in the model you can't always output
Rome or always Paris always I'll put
um those kinds of things so we also
wanted to be specific so this is the the
main two axes on which we measure the
edit yeah like what do you mean by
specific
um specific as in entities that aren't
related it's like subjects that aren't
related to the subject should not change
essentially yeah yeah so like you move
the Space Needle to Paris then we don't
want to move
um the uh the Statue of Liberty to Paris
at the same time or the uh or the Louvre
shouldn't
um you know should stay in Paris uh what
else what else is in Seattle uh Pike's
Place
to Paris along with the Space Needle she
just moved one thing and so you know the
interesting thing is that there does
seem to be the trade-off between being
really specific about making a change
and having the change uh be General and
um and if you sort of change a model
without paying too much attention to uh
exactly what you're doing uh it's really
easy to change a model in a way that is
completely generalized but not specific
at all like everything moves to Paris or
vice versa uh where
um where it's extremely specific but not
generalized at all where you have a very
specific wording of a sentence where now
it predicts Paris but if you change any
little detail then it has no idea what
you're talking about before you you said
like okay we can edit these models and
so on but there are differences and
these are the things that you compare
with in your evaluation so you you have
uh one evaluation is this zero shot
relation extraction but as I understand
it it's not exactly made for your use
case uh and uh we need to go further so
you also provide a new data set yeah so
a zero shot relation extraction is cool
because a lot of previous Works in model
editing have used it as a baseline
um and it it actually is is quite good
like you have a bunch of facts you can
rewrite we can paraphrase them I believe
that the ones that we have in our zsre
data set are the ones that previous
Works have used are are back translated
so we have a few paraphrases
um and then we sample a random fact from
I guess the other facts and check that
it changes
um so as we can see in the results the
there there is a there is resolution to
the method like we can see various
differences in paraphrase and drawdown
um but actually the resolution isn't too
high especially in drawdown like it's
hard for any of the really randomly
sample facts to be to be messed up even
by models that make quite large changes
and also moreover there's no evaluation
of fluency it's one thing to measure the
next token probabilities but it's also
another question of have we ruined the
fluency of the model have we deleted so
much syntactical knowledge that GPT
doesn't generate actual fluent text
anymore so those are the few those are a
few of the questions that motivate
um the design of counterfact which we
talk about in the next section so
counter fact is based on something
that's very similar to the SRE it's
actually called parallel it's a bunch of
relations that some researchers use to
analyze how consistent language models
are
um and basically it's just a bunch of
facts it's they're all in the form
subject relation object and what we do
is we want to test how well the model
how well the model can be taught facts
that aren't already true because
sometimes if you teach it something that
it already knows we might inflate the
numbers so we actually take the objects
in all of peril and we swap them around
we make everything not true
um and then we design a few other things
that can help us capture generalization
and specificity generalization works
very similarly to how Z SRE Works where
we just paraphrase a bunch of stuff but
specificity is a little bit different
because we found that because of the way
that the math works because we're we're
setting the output of one key to a
specific value if any other keys are in
the vicinity of the key that we input or
that we edited into the into the memory
those are pretty vulnerable to moving
around and so what we did for
specificity was we looked for
neighboring entities that are somewhat
related to the to the subject and
specifically they're related to the
subject because they have a common
predicate or the exact same predicate so
if I have the Eiffel Tower and we move
it to Rome then I will look for other
things that used to be in Paris like the
Louvre
um or the xiaomi Lisa things like that
and so that's one of the differences
that specificity uses
um there's also this fluency and
consistency thing which both deal with
generation metrics so fluency is pretty
straightforward we make it generate some
text and we want to see if it's fluent
but then with consistency
um we just let the model say whatever it
wants about the subject and we want to
see if the keywords that it's outputting
actually make sense for example if I
change the Eiffel Tower to be in Rome I
probably shouldn't see a lot of French
vocabulary I shouldn't see a lot about
you know the food that's in France or
the the attractions that are in Paris or
if I move a basketball player to being a
football player he shouldn't be winning
the NBA Championship he should be
winning the NFL Championship or
something like that
um and so that's another thing that we
do but our hope is that or we design
counter facts so that when you look at
all of these five things together you
get
um a bit of a more complete picture as
to what happens to your model after you
perform some kind of change you you've
talked a bit about yeah generating this
data set seeing you know does some thing
makes sense and so on now we talked
about budget before is it fair to assume
that this data set has at least in part
been also generated with the help of
automated things like models or is being
also evaluated with the help of of
automated heuristics
ah yeah okay so this data set was
actually generated completely
computationally
um and that's one of the that's one of
the big things with evaluating language
right it's it's very hard to design
computational metrics that align with
human judgment is is the short thing so
we actually include a a human evaluation
I don't know if we've archived it yet
we wanted to balance a few things but
the really nice thing about having
things computationally generated is it's
very easy to scale it up so I think one
of the secrets and the tricks behind a
lot of this knowledge-based work is it
actually Builds on top of
um big knowledge graphs and big
knowledge bases that have been curated
by a lot of people over time so so I
think the the underlying data underneath
parallel parallel and underneath that
kind of fact is actually Wiki data
um and so uh so yeah how do we get this
huge store of predicates uh to scramble
and you know related entities to uh to
um to uh to test they you know basically
they come from wikidata
um and so that's that's that's where
that's where we can get the scale for
this kind of thing
so down here you have an example of just
one of the edits uh that you make into
the model so we're dealing with a gpt2
model right here and what do we see like
what what is this here
that is the original fact that the model
outputs yep that's correct and then you
decide no actually Pierre curie's area
of work is medicine now we haven't
talked about yet let's go through this
uh step by step maybe Ah that's it
that's a joke in two days work World
um but we're a one-step method
so uh how would we go about this because
we haven't talked about like a final
piece of the puzzle yet
um we we talked about once we have a key
and value Vector right how do we insert
it into an MLP how do we edit it but
essentially this now here somehow has to
be made into some sort of key and some
sort of value so how do we get these
things
yeah that's a great question so the key
is a little bit more straightforward
because the natural interpretation of
the memory is that once it sees a key
it'll always output a value and even if
it's in the neighborhood it'll probably
output a similar value
so what we can do is we can simply show
the model the subject and it'll do its
computations and we can collect the
activation right before it goes in to
the MLP that we're targeting and that's
simply our key if we want to average
across context we can append some text
before the subject so that it gets to
see you know what happens when what
happens to the key when I have you know
five words in front of the subject or
ten words or something like that and
usually it doesn't change too much but
it helps with generalization but then
the value is a little bit more involved
and this is actually an interesting area
for future research because there are a
few things there are lots of things that
you could imagine V could be like in the
most simple clean case we would hope
that maybe V corresponds to an embedding
for example so if we want to you know
increase the signal for medicine we
could just add the embedding for
medicine or some transformation of the
embedding but as you pointed out earlier
it's it's not quite simple it's not
quite that simple because there are a
lot of things that are being stored for
Curie and one of them is that he works
in in physics or medicine but also you
need to know that he was living in a
certain country he was born in a certain
time period he had friends X Y and Z all
these kinds of things
um so the embedding thing is a little
bit simplistic but it's a super nice
ideal to Chase and I think that's an
interesting it's an interesting like
direction of future research basically
what we do is we perform a little
optimization it's a very constrained
optimization because it's operating only
on one on on one vector basically what
we say is so the MLP outputs some kind
of value we know that this value is
causally important because of the causal
tracing stuff so the question is how can
we tweak this Vector so that the new
fact is represented instead of the old
fact so we can perform a little
optimization we can say
given that the model currently thinks
the answer is you know Eiffel Tower is
located in Paris let's optimize it so
that it wants to say Rome instead and we
don't optimize any weights we don't
optimize a huge Matrix we optimize this
one little Vector that comes out of the
MLP and just changing that Vector will
allow us to change
um the the final prediction and in in
this sense like the um the optimization
takes into account the relation as well
because uh the back propagation goes
through all the tokens that describe the
relation
um and so that's sort of what we do that
gives us a um
a vector that'll that'll represent the
new fact do you want to talk about the
tricky second term that you have here
yeah sure so this is again indicative of
an interesting future research question
but one of the things that we observed
and this is sort of like a limitation
it's an interesting limitation is that
it's very hard to catalog all the things
that come out about the subject when you
when you you know feed the key into the
MLP so there could be a lot of things
and what we've observed is that
sometimes we'll observe we'll see this
thing called Essence drift which is
basically some of the old properties
about the subject will change when we
didn't want them to change like an
example of this is say
um you wanted to change Mario Kart to a
Microsoft product if you make the update
too strong it'll actually think Mario
Kart is no longer a game it'll think
it's a Microsoft Office productivity
tool yeah and
um so this this this this lost term
right here is just to encourage it to
not do that it's basically saying
there's some probability distribution
over or you know what this subject is
like the essence of the subject and we
want to keep it consistent up to like a
a weighting Factor so
admittedly it's a little bit of a hack
but you know I think it's it's it's it's
useful and um it raises this interesting
question of you know how can we decode
the vector the V space as well yeah and
it's and it's simple in the end right
it's um I think it takes a few seconds
to figure out one of these vectors uh
and then you can directly write it into
the into the network
yeah it's important to see that these
things here choosing the K vector and
ultimately choosing the the V Vector are
only to figure out the vectors that you
then want to put into the network this
optimization procedure doesn't actually
change anything in the network but it's
interesting because before you said
essentially well we're worried about the
keys because keys in the vicinity are
subject to change but now it also turns
out that actually values in the vicinity
are also subject to change so if I
change the value of a given subject I
need to tell the model by the way the
rest of the subject is kind of unchanged
right yeah it's you know it's it's
really counterintuitive right we have
this 1600 you know 2000 dimensional
Vector spaces and I I feel like our
intuition sometimes fails less you know
these Vector spaces are so big uh you
know you really have to you have to
respect that you can store a lot of
information in just a single vector
yes which which is so my last question
of this would be how do you choose the
MLP because here you need to Target like
a specific MLP at a specific layer in
the network how do you choose where you
want to make that edit yeah
um so this is uh this is a this is yet
another interesting question that kind
of foreshadows some of the work that we
do in our in our next paper
um but causal tracing gives us sort of a
range of MLPs at which it works and kind
of the observation with Rome is that we
wanted to make things as simple as
possible and it's fascinating that it
works and and possibly you know a
plausible reason for this for this
Simplicity is that there's the residual
stream that all these MLPs are
contributing towards the head and state
in an additive fashion so
um within the band of MLPs that we see
high causal effect for it's it's
plausible that this fact could be stored
in any of them and if any one of them
kind of overrides the previous ones then
we'll get you know the new fact being
expressed and so specifically what we do
is we just go to the causal traces and
we see where the causal effect Peaks and
then you know we run an experiment that
shows that this corresponds pretty well
to where the best edit occurs
um but basically it's um it's
interesting because when you start
adding more facts and you need more
capacity the question becomes you know
the question becomes well how do we
spread facts across layers so so you
know what we do is really so but like so
in a word what we do is really simple
and actually reviewers didn't really
like this as much right you know in
gpt2xl we use layer 17. right you know
we we do this you know causal Trace
analysis and we find that the causal
effects Peak there and we just say you
know we have all these thousands of
facts that we're testing on
we'll just test how well they all can be
stored in this specific
single Matrix at layer 17 and it works
pretty darn well
um and uh you know really I think it
sort of surprised reviewers there you
know they're like really you know are
you I I is this all you're doing and
um uh but you know I I think I think um
you know it's sort of I think the lesson
is you know if you really map out the
mechanisms inside the network you can
get a sense for where things are getting
done and you can find the specific
location that's most decisive now I it
like you're about to talk about scaling
and so I think that if you're trying to
insert lots of facts and maybe trying to
pile them all into the same Matrix uh
might not scale that well but for this
test that we're doing for this paper for
you know asking how well can a network
absorb a single new written fact you
know we found that the exact layer that
you use
may not be so important if we just
picked the single layer that's most
effective then it works for all these
facts so we end up in a situation where
we started off by thinking well we have
this distributed Network distributed
representations then you come in and say
no actually things are fairly localized
right they are and not not only fairly
localized but actually surprisingly for
example the fact that the Space Needle
might be in Seattle might already be
present after the model has consumed
Space Needle as a subject right which is
fairly surprising yet now we we almost
let go a half step back and say but
within that band within sort of that
localized area still it might be the
case that these facts are at least a
little bit distributed right over maybe
a bunch of layers adding to the residual
stream which also it's also fascinating
that you're saying well all if I edit
um if I edit some game to now be a
Microsoft game then all of a sudden it
might think you know it's it's a
Microsoft Office product or something
like this it's Super Mario is no longer
a game which kind of means that sort of
this this
these fact things here
they are not so clean they are still
kind of in super positions with each
other right if I if I change one then
the others also change a little bit so I
think I I think I think the jury is
still out on that like what the
structure of that Vector space is
um and um uh you know I think there's a
difference between uh
knowing whether
uh
information is really entangled in that
representation or or maybe we just
haven't developed the right lens or the
right method for disentangling the
information that's in there yeah
I've seen I think this morning I've seen
a a
statistic essentially listing that as
you scale up models uh most of the flops
let's say in in training and in
inference actually go into the feed
forward layers into the MLPs and not
necessarily into the attention uh
mechanisms everyone's always trying to
make attention more efficient while not
realizing that if you really go to these
big models they work in very high Vector
spaces and the feed forward layer in a
high Vector space is actually really
really expensive do you think that that
fact that we operate in essentially
large dimensions and so on that these
feed forward layers are so big do you
think that might be a main contributor
to these models essentially performing
really well and knowing a lot of things
it would make sense given what you found
I I think so I I think these these fan
out fan in feed forward layers are
really sponges for information they can
absorb a huge amount of basically
memorized information and so some of
that information uh you know our paper
is showing some of that information is
memorized uh factual associations
but I think there's a lot of other
information that's probably in these
matrices well you know information about
grammar and lower level things
um and so I think that you know they're
they're an amazing data structure for
um
for knowing a lot
uh some of the newer Transformers they
add some gating
to these MLP layers to you know increase
their capacity even further
um and so I do think it's they're sort
of one of the unsung heroes of these big
Transformer networks these these these
huge massive high-capacity memories last
question from my side
do you
there's a lot of discussion always about
what do these models understand now
understand is a weak word a wishy-washy
word let's say but what is your
impression like it seems that they they
certainly do more than just statistical
Association of kind of tokens uh to each
other like what what what's your current
understanding of what are the real
understanding capabilities of these
models do you want to answer that
question let me say something yeah
if you you if we if we answer this
question then somebody's going to boo us
um so so I think that uh so here here's
here here's what it seems like to me
there's there's like positive surprises
and some negative surprises and so so on
the positive side
um it was really really surprising to
see that a rank one update
in a single layer in a matrix
roughly corresponds to what a human
thinks of as a fact and we like there's
there's no particular reason that
resolution should match so well right
you know it it could be that a little
rank one change in a matrix is much
smaller than what a human thinks of is a
fact or it could be much bigger but it
actually is kind of surprising that it
pretty much matches up pretty well
um and so that's that's really
interesting and it raises a bunch of
philosophical questions about you know
what is the nature of knowledge what is
the nature of you know um the emergence
of ideas and big neural networks and so
on but but it's but it's pretty cool
um the um uh the the on the negative
side there's funny things about
um the mechanisms that don't really
correspond to the way that people think
so I think that the simplest example is
like if you reverse the statement of a
fact then these Transformers they
process it
differently so for example if um if you
said uh Bill Gates yeah oh yeah Bill
Gates Bill Gates is like Bill Gates is
the CEO of Microsoft or found it or
maybe or oh yes was yeah Bill Gates was
the founder of Microsoft right that's
you know anymore he's retired uh so but
if you if you said you know for example
like if you said Bill Gates was the
founder of Microsoft then then you could
find that
um that Association somewhere in the
network but if you if you if you had the
network know that it doesn't necessarily
also know that the founder of Microsoft
is Bill Gates because now you've used
the other entity as the key and that
would that would be potentially stored
separately so if you edited one of those
facts then the other fact wouldn't
automatically be edited you might need a
second edit and um and so you know
that's a little count intuitive I think
that you know if you ask the person is
that one fact they'd say oh yeah that's
a symmetric fact you know you told me
one of those I would know the other but
for a Transformer this may not be the
case it's uh it may be two separate
facts and that might be I mean it might
be a property of the sort of causal
masking that we're doing right because
only be able to sort of look back into
the sentence already means that you have
to pre-compute a lot of this knowledge
upon seeing the subject right and that
might be different paths through the
network for the different subjects so
for once subject is Bill Gates and for
the other one's object is Microsoft you
don't know what's coming at the end of
the sentence and therefore you need to
be kind of prepared for everything so
maybe bi-directional models might have
this differently maybe maybe or or you
could imagine it the other way because
you could also Imagine while people are
constrained to live forward in time so
the way we must think about language
must also be you know so so you have
this debate about what is what is the
best way uh to think about it and um and
so uh so so yeah
um
there's that there's that movie arrival
I sort of imagined that maybe all the
arrival aliens uh you know they they
sort of had a bi-directional Transformer
uh you know brains for their language
model and and as humans were stuck with
these you know one your unidirectional
GPT style models and uh and that's it's
really hard to communicate between them
okay cool
um Kevin and David it was a it was a
real pleasure having you here as as I
said I linked the new paper for sure uh
and yeah do you have any last things
that you want to get out there to people
maybe
um how can they get into this field of
of knowledge editing and uh
figuring out what these things know what
I what I don't understand so here's my
here's my you know question for the
machine Learning Community out there
what I don't understand is why why isn't
our entire field about cracking open
these miles and looking at what's inside
them I think that we're getting better
and better at getting
really interesting capabilities out of
the models but they contain so many
mysteries in there if you think about
the number of billions of parameters
inside gpd3 you know that just like this
machine learned code
is
you know it's larger than the entire
code base of you know massive companies
that have employed tens of thousands of
people to produce you know manually
produce code for many years
you know these these large models they
must contain a lot of interesting uh
structures so so I guess my you know my
my advice is you know crack open models
uh there's there's surely a lot of
interesting stuff to discover inside
them awesome Kevin last words
yeah no I think this field is very
exciting not only for the I I think the
science is amazing but I also think it's
it's cool because it inspires
interesting questions about what we can
do to make these things better like some
of the negative surprises that we found
with you know trying to to see if GPT
really understands certain Concepts is
that you know the the observation that
there's this bi-directionality of
knowledge could only have emerged once
we developed a method to edit things to
see how things work
um so I think it's really cool that this
kind of stuff can can be raised by
interpretability research and it'll help
us build better safer models uh in the
long run that we can actually engineer
and I think that's really exciting all
right cool well thanks so much for being
here and uh best of best of uh not luck
best of success for the for the future
papers thanks Yannick thank you it was
really really nice of you to to
interview us and it's really great to
meet you here thank you
[Music]
thank you